descendants 3-star Sarah Jeffrey is
making her mark on the Billboard Hot 100
with her first solo track from the
franchise
yeah the Vancouver native knew the song
was something special she tells
Billboard when I heard it for the first
time I got emotional I was like wow this
is so beautiful I'm genuinely so
grateful and excited in a song like that
was written for me and now it's turning
into a major hit on the charts after
debuting at number 67 on the hot 100 it
moved up to number 49 this week Sarah
says of the song success I didn't expect
it to gain so much popularity so quickly
you don't really know how people are
going to react to it if it's going to
land and it's just impossible to predict
but I'm so grateful that this thing that
I worked really hard on and we're so
excited about is getting recognition
it's actually the first song from a
Disney Channel show to chart this high
since this is me from Camp Rock and a
member that's our favorite time yeah
here's a bit of queen of mean toy train
I'm feeling like a perfect picture with
a broken frame clean
[Music]
[Applause]
on the shoulder with angel
and
no thought reminds me a little bit of
you're gonna say fellas that's it let it
go yeah the subject matter is similar
it's like you're like embracing her her
there's no power there's something in
the in the music and the melody to that
made me think of it I don't know exactly
what it was but I had that thought as
well which is not a terrible thing I
don't know how well did that song and
but even though has like some feel of
pop music Avril Lavigne a little bit in
there yeah so it's interesting like I
feel like this might be one of those
songs that just has kind of a cultural
moment like that's what happened I
remember when Old Town Road first came
out before it hit number one yes you
just knew like this song might be
something in a member that happen would
let it go to you gets kind of see the
ground swell so as a song is yeah it's
kind of like making some real surprises
on the charts and couldn't definitely
see it explode yeah
so you'll see queen of mean waiting up
me